yeah this is how you sequel you make a
sequel that no one was really asking for
it if it's great awesome if not who
cares
[Music]
Jumanji welcome to the jungle
so Jumanji welcome to the jungle is a
new Jumanji adventure instead of having
a board game it's a video game now monji
rules with the time and it kind of a
Breakfast Club scenario for people in
high school who usually wouldn't hang
out together end up in detention
together they see this video game they
turn it on they pick their characters
are sucked into the video games that's
the humours start to the fact that their
avatars in the video game are not really
like them movie stars the rock Kevin
Hart Jack Black Karen Gillan and here we
go on their adventure in a movie that's
probably I laughed more in this movie
than a lot of comedies this year
companies have been pretty light this
year this movie's a comedy adventure
this is a comedy that wins it's just how
you do comedy for me first of all the
cast completely works together and
individually they're all charismatic
they're all charming they do their jobs
well you don't really see them do a lot
they haven't done before you've seen the
rock do comedic moments before and every
time he does I'm always like that's
right the guy's funny but Kevin Hart
plays Kevin Hart granted he plays Kevin
Hart very well in that TJ Miller kind of
way you know when TJ Miller's in a movie
you're like his TJ Miller in a TJ Miller
role on another end of the spectrum
that's Kevin Hart when I see him in
movies he plays a Kevin Hart character
the funny thing about his character he's
the character were a high school version
of his character named the grown up
Jumanji version of his character they
don't really match for me the thing they
have in common is that they are in fact
both black but he's like he's kind of a
stoic football player then he gets into
the game and he's a really fast talking
guy give me nerdy dude becomes the rock
the Instagram princess becomes Jack
Black and the social outcast nerd girl
becomes karen gillan Jack Black mad jack
black plays a high school girl like a
really hot cheerleader high school
Instagram princess and the way he
doesn't the humor involved in it I'm
like I don't think anyone but Jack Black
could have done it that well I'm a big
gamer nerd you guys know that so the way
this movie addresses videogames I found
really entertaining life bars menus
backpacks our strengths weaknesses all
of them very video games all of them do
make you laugh because in video games it
is a bit absurd how many times you play
The Legend of Zelda and you're like how
many items can you fit in that backpack
this movie dresses that and it's quite
as terrible so it is a video game movie
that's not actually a video game movie
because it's not actually a movie based
on a video game proper
but it uses the videogame element and
angle to its advantage and that's what
really works for it and this is supposed
to be a video game so the action
sequences they were really exciting to
see where the rock is like alright I
have super strength let's just get down
he's just beating these enemies down
alright this is exciting in that video
game kind of way ever just go into a
zone in a video game you've clearly
advanced you've leveled past but you
want to go back there just a wreck shop
is like that it was fun now the bad guy
in this movie really doesn't stand out
for me I feel like they're gone not only
the MCU route I feel like that's the
route in movies in general as long as
you have a good ensemble of heroes that
come together the villain just kind of
takes a hit on that the villains the
weakest part of a lot of movies these
days there's movies no different I don't
remember the villains name I don't even
remember anything he really does he's
just out there but really it's
concentrating on them and their
adventure I would have liked to have
seen a character like the original
Jumanji that hunter that dude scared me
it was terrifying you knew he was always
on the hunt for them and if they ever
crossed his path they needed to run this
dude is not so many thing like that and
as this movie really landed and
resonated with me it does rely so
heavy-handed on the video game humor or
the humor based around video games and
knowing how video games work but if
you're not so into video games I don't
know how this movie is going to affect
you I don't know how it's gonna click
with you I mean it can still click with
you I think he'll still have fun with it
but will you really be like you had
who's speaking to my heart but in the
end Jumanji has got to be the surprise
of the year at least the past few months
it was funny it was exciting it actually
had a few moments of heart surprising
heart I was like that that's - that's
hit me - my home what's up I walked out
of this movie having had a blast and I
will say Jumanji is a great time no
alcohol require even Karen Gillan's
outfit that the internet went nuts over
like why is she wearing that outfit in
the juggle successful it is betraying a
video game so there is a reason for it
they do address it maybe you should
teach Twitter and the rest of the
internet maybe people should take a step
back breathe for a second maybe think
there might be a good reason for it and
we'll just see how it plays out when the
movie comes out alright so Jumanji
welcome to the jungle have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]